Ajax stands for asynchronous JavaScript
and XML a checked allows you to update
parts of a website without reloading the
entire page you can receive data from a
server and send data to a server in the
background here's an example so we have
the HTML code setup up here then we have
the Java Script which has the Ajax down
here and then over here is is the actual
web page right on the side here now
let's see what happens when I push this
change content button see the text is
now changed to subscribe to the free
code camp YouTube channel that text is
actually nowhere in this code anywhere
because that text is coming from another
server I'm going to go through all this
coding detail but first I want to give
you an overview of the seven main steps
to Ajax so the first step is that an
event occurs on a web page so that's
this see we have the button up here so
the event is when you hit the button the
second step is that an XML HTTP request
object is created by JavaScript now
that's right here it says new XML HTTP
request the third step is that the xml
httprequest object sends a request to
the web server now that's the part down
here where we have the web server right
there and then we're going to send this
request down here X HTTP send the next
step is that the server processes the
request now that happens at the server
that we were making their quest of then
the fifth step is that the server sends
a response back to the web page also at
the other server the sixth step is that
the response is read by JavaScript and
if you look up here I can explain this
more in detail in just a second but
where it says this that response text is
where we get the response from the
server the seventh step is that the
proper action like a page update is
performed by JavaScript so that's also
in this line we're going to update the
HTML on the website with JavaScript so
now I'm going to go through this code in
detail I'm going to start actually with
this line right here the actual file
we're trying to get is this one right
here the HTTP colon slash slash carves
out CC flash code /h X underscore
example that txt now we also have this
other thing right
this work says cross-origin me now this
is a Korres proxy which is a service
that allows developers to access
resources from other websites when they
would normally be a cross-origin error
now if I didn't have this right before
it I would get this error down here
where it says it basically cannot load
that file or it says no access control
origin header is present on the
requested resource basically this is a
security feature where I'm on code pin
right now you cannot just easily pull
files from another web server now this
is just a basic short-term solution
using a proxy like this it's a
short-term solution it's just a quick
fix if you want to try things out the
long term solution would be to update
the htx s file on the server for cons
SEC to allow cross-origin requests and
then I can make this request without
adding the proxy at the beginning okay
let's go back to the rest of this code
here first of all you can see that in
the HTML when you click the button it's
gonna call this function and that's just
right in the JavaScript then we're gonna
create the XML HTTP request we're gonna
treat this object in JavaScript now
we're gonna use this property we're
gonna set this property the
onreadystatechange property this
property defines a function to be called
when the ready state property changes
and you can see the ready state property
right here we're gonna use their list
ready state the ready state property is
going to be one of four numbers zero the
requests not initialized one server
connection established two requests
received three processing requests for
requests finished and response is ready
so that's where we get to this next line
if this that rate state equals equals 4
that means that the request is finished
and the response is ready and this that
status equals equals 200 now this is an
HTML response so 200 means okay another
common status would be 404 which means
not found so 200 means that the resource
resource was found on the server and
what resource well we haven't got to
that yet but so this just means if we
got a good response in the request
finished and it was found then we can do
something with the response so
go on to this line right here so we're
about to set something on the website
document dot get element by ID so the
idea is right here ID equals demo we're
gonna set the innerhtml that means we're
gonna change its HTML between the tags
that have the ID demo and we're going to
set this text to this dot response text
this that response text just returns the
data as a string from the from the
server we could use this dot response
XML if we want XML returned let's do
another example of this I'm gonna reset
this it starts with let Ajax changes
text click change content and then we
just gotten this information from
another server and if we go down here
the open function is where we specify
what file or resource we are requesting
but this does not actually request it
yet here we use get we can also use post
if you are sending a large amount of
data to the server or sending user input
you should use post here but otherwise
you use you should usually use get and
then we actually put where the resources
located what website we're trying to get
something from and this last thing true
this is for whether or not the request
is asynchronous you almost always want
true for asynchronous so you can execute
other scripts while waiting for a server
response now this last thing right here
the X HTTP dot send function is where we
actually send the request to the server
so this just means do everything we set
up to do these previous things with the
X HTTP object and then after the request
changes the ready state it will call
this function this was just a brief
introduction to ajax if you want to
learn more check out the links in the
description thanks for watching my name
is beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good